This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all heard the urban legend of the mother, who upon finding her child trapped under a car, is able to summon superhuman strength to lift the vehicle from the ground and save her child. It turns out, this truth to the legend. In 1982, Angela Kavalo's son was working on a Chevy Impala when it fell on top of him. Angela lifted the car high enough off the ground that two neighbors could pull her son to safety.
A similar event happened in 2019 when an Ohio teen lifted a car to save his neighbor's life. In 2006, a Canadian woman saved a group of children, including her own two sons, by fighting off a polar bear. It's unclear, biologically, how people can summon God-like strength in scenarios like these. But it raises an interesting question. Are we all capable of more than we think? You often hear echoes of this theme in the biographies of famous people. At 21, Stephen Hawking was diagnosed with ALS and given only a few years to live.
He not only defied the odds and lived to the age of 76, he also went on to become one of the most brilliant theoretical physicists of all time. Bethany Hamilton was 13 when a shark bit off her left arm. She went on to become a professional surfer who has won multiple championships. It makes you think, doesn't it? What can I accomplish if I really set my mind and heart to it? What am I keeping myself from accomplishing by believing it to be impossible? The science of human potential and psychological insights on how to discover our potential,
this week on Hidden Brain. There's the old joke about how you get to Carnegie Hall. Practice, practice, practice. What keeps us from reaching our true potential in life? Well, that's easy. We should figure out what we ought to do and then do it. But like that joke about Carnegie Hall, the devil isn't the details. At the University of Pennsylvania, organizational psychologist Adam Grant has studied how, when, and why, our minds get bogged down by obstacles.
In his book, Hidden Potential, Adam explores the psychology of how we can become the best versions of ourselves. Adam Grant, welcome back to Hidden Brain. So glad to be back, Shankar. Thanks for having me. Adam, many years ago you were starting college and you knew you had an interest in psychology, but you were also really interested in physics. You signed up for a class with an very eminent astrophysicist. Tell me what class this was and how it went. It was a cosmology class and it was about understanding the universe.
I remember there was a shopping period where we got to sample all the classes we were interested in before they officially started. I went to the intro to astrophysics day and this professor seemed so dynamic. He loved physics. He was clearly an expert. He'd won tons of awards. He had many publications and you know I walked into class and thought this is gonna continue to ignite my interest in physics and it did not go as I hoped. I didn't understand it at all. I felt like an idiot and I gave up on physics.
The first reason we fail to reach our potential is the obvious one. We never get started. Something knocks us off course at the beginning of a journey and we don't go down that road. Years later we look back and ask, what if? Then there are situations where we do get started, but quickly get stuck. This happened to Adam, believe it or not, as he was writing the chapter in his book on how to get unstuck. It's ironic, isn't it?
I'm writing a whole chapter about how to get unstuck, and I just completely stalled in the middle of it. I cycle through so many different metaphors for getting unstuck. Some of them were embarrassingly bad. Getting unstuck is like having to demolish and renovate a building. And then it was going to be like, you have to uproot a plant. At one point I was digging a tunnel. Then there was a wall that you're trying to break through.
And these metaphors were really forced. And I spent weeks and weeks spinning my wheels on this. And finally, I just gave up. And I said, I have to put this chapter away and move on to something else because this is not moving forward. And I'm driving myself mad. I understand that you spend a lot of time watching the TV show Friends during this period. Yeah, I was definitely, I was chilling with Monica and Chandler, which mostly happened late
at night. So I was definitely guilty of what's been called Revenge Bedtime procrastination. Putting off going to sleep because I had a really miserable monotonous day. And now I'm going to get revenge and do something fun. And it did no good whatsoever. The feeling of being stuck comes with a psychological cost. It's not just that you are making no progress. You are acutely aware. You are making no progress, you are acutely aware you are making no progress.
Linguishing was first defined by the sociologist Corey Keys, but immortalized by everyone's favorite philosopher, Maria Carey. Keys defines languishing as a sense of emptiness and stagnation. Most of us would say, I feel meh or blah. You're not burned out, you still have some energy, but you're not at peak motivation. You don't have a full sense of purpose and progress. It's a bit of a vicious cycle because when you're languishing, you feel like you're stuck, but then it keeps you stuck. If you look at the evidence, one of the
challenges of languishing is that it disrupts focus and dulls motivation. So, you know, in my case, I stop trying new ideas, I stop writing, and then I just stay stuck. I want to talk about a final way we create mental blocks for ourselves. Let's say you do accomplish something big, you manage to push through obstacles, you reach a goal. Once you get to what feels like a top, it can be all too easy to go sliding down. Let's talk about an athlete Adam. In high school, R.A. Dickie was making a name for himself as a highly skilled baseball player.
He looked like he was headed somewhere. Tell me his story. R.A. Dickie was a phenom. He, I think he gets to his sophomore year of high school and there are already pro scouts showing up at his games. Wow. He gets to college and he wins an Olympic bronze medal. He's a starting pitcher for Team USA.
And he gets drafted in the first round by the Texas Rangers. He's offered a signing bonus of nearly a million dollars. And he knows he's going somewhere. He's going to start off at the very top of their minor league system. And then you give it a year or two and he'll make the major leagues. So he shows up to sign his contract in 1996 and a team trainer notices something odd about an X-ray. Tell me what he found.
Well, the trainer notices that his arm, it hangs at a strange angle. They do the X-ray and they discover that Ra is actually missing a ligament in his right elbow. He's born without it. He never knew. And it didn't seem to hold him back up until that point. But if you want to throw a blazing fastball, that ligament turns out to be pretty important. And it seems to put a ceiling on his potential.
That he's never going to hit 100 miles an hour. And the difference between throwing in the low 90s and a hundred is a huge deal for a major league pitcher. Did he still get his million dollar signing bonus? No, he did not. They cut it to less than $80,000. And they sent him to the bottom rungs of the minor league system.
So clearly this is someone who, again, felt like he was going somewhere, real spark, you know, sort of had caught lightning in a bottle and then suddenly feels like he's sliding back down the mountain. In his late 20s, Aure gets a break. The Rangers bring him up to the major's full time and it looks again like he had achieved his dream. Tell me what happens this time, Aure. Well, this is after seven years of toiling away in the minors,
trying to figure out, all right, if I can't throw as fast as I want to go, I'm going to mix up speed and spin, and I'm just going to trick batters. And that's going to be my competitive advantage. So he gets called up. He's in his late 20s. This is supposed to be the prime of his career. And he just bombs. If you read the coverage of his performance at the time and also his potential, people say he's mediocre, he loses more games than he wins. People start calling him a
has been and worse yet, I never was. And at some point, his manager is bringing men for a tough conversation. How does that unfold at him? It doesn't go well for him. They say to him, look, you're going nowhere. And he agrees with it. He realizes, you know what, this is not panning out for me. They send him back down to the minors. And I think it looks to a lot of people like his dream is over.
What happens next? Well, Aradiki is a determined human being. He's full of grit, so he spends his entire off season throwing pitches against Cinderblocks. He actually drives around in his car with a baseball in his right hand so he can practice his grip. He pushes himself harder than he's ever pushed himself in his right hand so he can practice his grip. He pushes himself harder than he's ever pushed himself in his life. And the next season he gets
another shot. His first game back in the majors. He ties a major league record. But Shankar it's not the kind of record that you want. He gives up six home runs in three innings and over a century of baseball, no picture has ever done worse. He gets booed right out of the game and sent back to the miners again, which feels to him like, strike three, you're out. Most of us are not professional athletes, but many of us have had this feeling. We catch a break, accomplish something, but then it seems like there's nowhere else to go but down. But it turns out there was more to our history as there is to yours.
When we come back, the most common strategies we all use to reach our potential and the science of whether they work. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. What are your wildest dreams? Do you want to write a book someday? Run a marathon? Maybe you've always wanted to climb Mount Everest. Sometimes our dreams seem so outlandish. We don't even voice them.
They seem grandiose. Of course, dismissing a goal before we get started on it is a sure-fire way to never achieving that goal. But when we do decide to work on an ambitious goal, there are common strategies most of us turn to. Psychologist Adam Grant says these solutions often don't work the way we think they work. Adam, when you were a freshman in high school, you played a lot of video games. One summer, your mom dragged you to the local swimming pool. Tell me what happened that day. I saw a lifeguard on his break get up on the diving board. Mom dragged you to the local swimming pool. Tell me what happened that day.
I saw a lifeguard on his break, get up on the diving board. And I remember watching him leap off the board and do a front two and a half, two flips, and then a dive, and then just vanish into the water. And I guess I'd seen diving on TV in the Olympics a few times. I'd never seen it up close and I was mesmerized. And I said, I wanna learn how to do that.
So you spend the rest of the summer learning some basic dives and then you show up at Fall Tryouts for the diving team. Your coach has both good news and bad news for you. Why don't we start with the bad news? He basically told me that I lacked a lot of the things that you would normally look for in a diver. I walked like Frankenstein. I couldn't touch my toes without bending my knees.
I couldn't jump high at all. I basically lacked the explosive power, flexibility, and grace that you expect in a diver. So what's the good news here? Well, that's what I was wondering. I was like, wait, is there good news? And the Keracharic Vests said to me, listen, diving is a nerd sport. It attracts the people who weren't quick enough for basketball or strong enough for football or fast enough for track.
If you work hard at this, by the time you're a senior, you can be a state finalist. All right, so you said there's a path for me here. I might not have the natural athletic skills, but I have the grit and the determination. Tell me what happened next. Did you apply yourself and learn to become a diver? I spent a lot of time walking down the board. I would do my approach. I would jump to the end of the board,
and I'd feel like I was off balance, or it wasn't going quite right, so I'd stop and turn around and start over, and I probably wasted at least half of every practice. Not ever taking off. I would bark on a basic front dive pike. I would still stop and start over because as I learned later, I was a perfectionist. Tell me about that, you were trying to perfect aspects of your dive as opposed to
sort of the overall, your overall ability to dive. Yeah, once I realized I was a perfectionist, I thought it was going to be an asset in diving because it would help me work toward perfect tense. But what it did was it led me to stop every time my approach wasn't perfect. It also led me to focus on the wrong things. I focused on the things that I actually could perfect, like taking my already good rip entry where I would hit the water and go, pff, and disappear without a splash.
And instead of working on getting better at harder dives, I was just obsessed with perfecting the tiny details of my existing easy dives. So in other words, you didn't have a very high vertical leap, for example, and you could have spent time working on that, and that could have helped you with any number of dives, but that's not what you were focused on. Now, I should have spent a lot of time improving my vertical leap, stretching to increase my flexibility, working on the big flaws in my diving, as
opposed to taking the skills that I was already pretty good at and refining those. You say there are three things that perfectionists often get wrong, that in some ways get in the way of people accomplishing their potential. What are those three things at them? The first mistake that perfectionists make is they obsess about tiny details that don't matter and they miss out on the big picture. Second challenge is that perfectionists end up narrowing their areas of growth. I think if perfectionism was medication, they would actually come with a warning label. Warning may cause stunted growth. If you're a perfectionist, you want to be flawless and that means if you're not going
to be good at something initially, you don't want to try because you might fail. And that means you stay within your comfort zone. You don't stretch beyond your strengths and you don't take on new challenges. And then the third issue is that perfectionists are master ruminators, constantly braiding themselves for their past mistakes. What they forget is that beating yourself up doesn't make you better. It leaves you bruised. So, besides perfectionism at him, a second thing we do when we're trying to unlock our potential
is to turn to experts for advice. And in some ways, the reasoning is obvious when we're interested in a subject but not sure where to start, you know, why not seek out people at the top of that game and learn from them, it makes intuitive sense. Does it work at him? That's as well as I expected. Why not seek out people at the top of that game and learn from them? It makes intuitive sense. Does it work at them? That as well as I expected.
The research that really blew my mind on this was looking at students at Northwestern. Or I think it was about a decade and a half looking at students in every possible subject, taking an intro class. And the question is, what happens to their grades in their next class in that subject? Based on whether they learned from an expert. If you had a tenured or tenured track professor for your intro class, you do worse in your next class. Then if
you have a teacher who's less of an expert, a lecturer or an adjunct instructor. That seems very surprising, doesn't it? Because the person you're saying that the person who actually knows more has a worse effect on you than the person who knows less? I think that's what the evidence suggests. And I think Einstein was a great example of this. Einstein obviously was brilliant,
but he really struggled to teach elementary physics. In fact, he only attracted a few students for one of his early courses, and then was forced to cancel the class the next semester when he couldn't recruit enough to fill the room. He came across his disorganized to his students because he knew too much, and all the dots connected in his head head and he could not relate as a genius and an expert to what it was like to be a beginner. And Shagger, I think that's part of what happened to me in my intro astrophysics class in college. I showed up there's this very knowledgeable expert teacher and
he's great at teaching PhD seminars, but not so skilled when it comes to, you know, freshman astrophysics when we've never seen any of this material before because it's been for him 40 years since he knew what it was like to not know. So we've talked about the downsides of perfectionism and the downsides of seeking out experts. I want to talk about a third thing that many of us do when we try to achieve our potential. We tell ourselves that we should push through roadblocks by becoming our own drill sergeants.
You've actually put this question to people. What do they tell you at them? I've heard time and time again that if you want to reach your potential, it's all about the daily grind. You have to push yourself as hard as you can. Yeah. Did you try and do this while you were getting stock on your book when you found yourself procrastinating? Did you say the way to do this is to essentially whip myself and try to try to finish up?
I did. Yeah, I thought, okay, what I need to do is I need to focus all my attention and energy on the stuck chapter and get unstuck. And block out distractions. Maybe the problem is divided attention. I'm doing too many projects right now. And so let me clear the deck. Let me just focus on this one thing. And you know what happened? I'm sitting there looking at the blinking cursor and it kind of feels like staring into the sun. Hmm. Why do you think this doesn't work?
Why do you think that being harsh on ourselves and saying I'm gonna be single-minded in what I'm doing? Why do you think it doesn't have the effect that we think it's gonna have? Um, I think there are a couple of reasons it can fail or even backfire. One is burnout.
You just exhaust yourself at some point. Two is what psychologists call bore out. You're literally bored out of your mind by doing the same task over and over. And three is that you're not opening yourself up to fresh perspectives and new ideas. If you just keep staring ahead, you're never going to see things through a different lens. There's a fourth era that you talk about that people often fall into when they try and achieve their goals. And this one is rather subtle.
People imagine that the path to their goals is linear. What do you mean by this atom? I think that most people think about success is a straight line. And they think, okay, I've got, you know, I've got to go through the following steps and then I'll land where I'd like to be. But if you look at the evidence, success is much more likely to be circular than linear. We often go in loops to get where we want to go. Look at the evidence, success is much more likely to be circular than linear. We often go in loops to get where we want to go.
It's much more of a squiggly or jagged line than it is a direct path, which is frustrating. But as you recognize that, it becomes a little bit easier to accept the fact that not every step is going to take you forward. Sometimes, you actually need to go one step backward to go two steps ahead. There was a study by the cognitive scientist Wayne Gray and John Linstett called Plato's Dips and Leaps. Tell me what it found. I think this is such an encouraging pattern for anybody who's ever plateaued or gotten stuck. They find this pattern across people trying to improve into all kinds of skills. What they show is that when people get stuck
and then they end up making a leap, usually there's a dip before the leap. In other words, they get worse before they get better. And I think an easy illustration of this is typing. If you wanna get faster at typing, if you like to hunt and peck, you're probably going to max out around 30 to 40 words a minute. You can keep practicing, but you're going to run into a wall because that method is only so good. If you want to get faster, you have to backtrack and learn a
different method, which is you're going to type by touch. You have to learn the home keys and not look at your fingers. Not look at the keyboard. And what's frustrating to a lot of people about that is, it's going to take you a little while to get comfortable with that method. And in order to speed up, you actually have to slow down. And that's, I think, an illustration of what happens in so many tasks is, you get stuck not because you've maxed tasks is you get stuck not because
you've maxed out on your potential, not because you've hit your peak, but because you've reached the limits of the method that you're using. And you need to go back to the drawing board and learn a new method to get better. When we want to accomplish big goals and reach our potential, we usually think we need to do certain things to get there. Pull ourselves up, focus on the task, and seek expert advice. It turns out those strategies are not as effective as we might think. So what does work?
When we come back, better techniques for tapping into our potential. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all encountered them. Overachievers, the students who scored near-perfect SATs, Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all encountered them. Overachievers. The students who score near-perfect SATs. Colleagues who consistently knock their milestones out of the park.
Athletes and entrepreneurs who start out looking no different from us, but end up looking very different. At the Wharton School, Psych Adam Grant says these less separating us from these high achievers than we might think. In his book Hidden Potential, the science of achieving greater things, Adam offers a number of strategies that can help us get where we want to go. Adam when you were writing the book you told me that you felt like you were languishing, you were bored and the project felt stagnant.
You found it very easy to get distracted. We talked earlier about how most people think the solution to this is to just block out those distractions and power through, but you learned a different lesson from playing Scrabble. I did. I was actually playing words with friends. You know, at some point I just threw my hands up and said,
I cannot make progress on this chapter right now. And I picked up my phone and I went into a Words with Friends game. And then I remember I had a bunch of letters. I had, I think it spelled out, Roud Noy, if I remember correctly. And I realized if I rearranged those letters, I could, if I could find an open eye on the board, I could make the word original. And I did it, there was an eye, and I scored this bingo.
And all of a sudden, I got this jolt of, wait a minute, I'm not completely incompetent, I'm not incapable of everything. I feel like I just made a little progress there. How do you know this was not just more procrastination at it? I don't. It might have been. But I found in my research with G. Hay Shin that sometimes there are unexpected benefits of procrastinating. A lot of people think that procrastination is caused by laziness. And you feel like, well, I'm not motivated enough or I'm just not willing to work hard enough
and you berate yourself for that. But psychologists like Fuchsia Sourwaha have found that procrastination is actually not caused by laziness. You're not afraid of hard work. What you're avoiding are negative emotions that a task stirs up. In some situations it's boredom. In others it's confusion.
For many people it's fear and anxiety. I don't know if I can do this. For me it was frustration and confusion in that moment. I feel like I've hit a wall. I don't know where to go. I can't figure this out. You cite research that shows that when people take on serious hobbies, their confidence climbs at work, but only if the hobbies are in a different area from their jobs.
Can you talk about this work? Yeah, if you take a detour to try to master something completely unrelated to your job, it tends to build your sense of self-afficacy. This is exactly what happened to me playing words with friends. You come away thinking, all right, I can do that. And so it's a completely different task that gives you a chance to recharge your confidence and reboot your motivation. And in some ways, is this really about feeding like you can, you know, notch some wins in some domain. So even if you're stuck in a primary domain that you care about,
being able to notch a win in a secondary domain tells you, sort of sends you, it gives you a psychological jolt and maybe helps you when you come back to the primary domain. It does a sense of progress in one part of your life, really reinforces your, your belief in your own capability and one part of your life, really reinforces your belief in your own capability and other parts of your life. You once ran a study that looked at the relationship between procrastination and creativity. Tell me what you found.
We basically found that there's a sweet spot of procrastination for creativity, that people who didn't procrastinate were less creative than people who would put things off a little bit. And then when G.H.H.H.H.H. showed me those results, I remember asking her, like, what about the chronic procrastinators who put things off a lot? And she was like, I don't know,
they didn't fill out my survey. No, they didn't fill out the survey. No, they didn't fill out the survey eventually. And they were less creative too. Interesting. As rated by their supervisors. And I think what's going on here, we designed a series of experiments to get to the bottom of this. What's going on here is that if you dive right in, you're rushing ahead with your first
idea as opposed to waiting for your best idea. If you wait till the last minute, you're also rushing because you now have to implement your easiest idea as opposed to your best idea. And the sweet spot in the middle is where you have time to incubate. You're more likely to reframe the problem. You're more likely to access some unexpected ideas and you know and take some random walks and maybe have a eureka moment But you still have the time to to really work out the most promising idea But there's a really important caveat here which is that a little bit of procrastination only Contributed to creativity when people were intrinsically motivated
By the problem they were putting off so if you're just completely bored by the task, guess what? It's not going to be active in the back of your mind when you're procrastinating. It's only if you're interested in the problem and you're putting it off because it's hard or you haven't figured it out yet, that you do the subconscious processing that can be helpful with unlocking a solution. Hmm. You know, I'm reminded of a story involving the late great psychologist, Amos Tversky, when he and Danny Kahneman were developing the foundations of what would become behavioral economics. Amos and Danny would spend a lot of time just sort of chatting and joking and people would
say, how come you guys are not writing papers? You just seem to be having a good time. And Amos said that people sometimes waste years because they're not willing to waste days. And I might be paraphrasing what he said. But basically the point is, in their zeal to sort of jump in and get stuff done very quickly, people sometimes are not giving themselves the room
to actually figure out what it is that they should actually be working on. And yes, you might be making progress in the short run, but in fact that progress comes at the cost of how far you can get in the long run. It's a really wise observation, and there's actually a term for it now. It's called the plunging in bias. My collaborator, Rev. Rebully, I thought had a great way of capturing how to overcome that. He said, you can still be quick to start, but make sure you're not too quick to finish. So, I want to go back to the topic of perfectionism that we talked about earlier. We think of highly skilled people as perfectionists, but this is not always the case. You say that elite musicians, for example, are less driven by an obsessive
去真正搞清楚他们到底应该在做什么。是的，你可能在短期内取得了进展，但事实上，这种进展是以牺牲你长远能走多远为代价的。这是一个非常明智的观察，现在其实有一个专门的名词来形容它，叫做“陷入偏见”。我的合作者雷夫·雷布利（Rev. Rebully）对如何克服这一点有一个很好的看法。他说，你起步可以快，但一定要确保收尾别太快。所以，我想回到我们刚才讨论过的完美主义这个话题。我们认为高技能的人都是完美主义者，但事实并非总是如此。你说，例如，精英音乐家受对完美的强迫性执念驱使较少，更多的是由一种你称之为“和谐激情”的东西所驱动。你这个词是什么意思？当心理学家谈论和谐激情时，他们基本上是指让这项任务与你自己的兴趣水平相契合。所以你不是因为不得不做而逼迫自己去做。你不是一个强迫性的工作狂。你做这件事是因为你热爱它，因为你喜欢在其中挑战自我，因为你想把它做得更好。
compulsion to be perfect and more fueled by something that you call harmonious passion. What do you mean by this term? When psychologists talk about harmonious passion, they're basically talking about having the task in harmony with your own level of interest. So you're not pushing yourself to do it because you have to. You're not an obsessive compulsive workaholic. You're doing it because you love it, because you enjoy challenging yourself at it, because you want to get better at it.
In other words, you're actually... It's not just that you're playing the music and saying, I want the music to be perfect, but at some level, you're actually enjoying the music, which, I want the music to be perfect, but at some level you're actually enjoying the music, which, I mean, at one level seems sort of self-evident. How can you be a musician if you don't enjoy the music? But I suspect there are probably many musicians who are no longer enjoying the music,
换句话说，实际上……不仅仅是你在演奏音乐时说，我希望音乐完美，而是在某种程度上，你其实是在享受音乐——这，我希望音乐完美，但在某种程度上你其实是在享受音乐——这，我的意思是，从某种层面来看似乎是不言而喻的。如果不享受音乐，你怎么能成为一名音乐家？但我猜可能有很多音乐家已经不再享受音乐了，
because they're just going through the technical act of producing the music. Yeah, or they're focused on the outcome. And they're less likely to get absorbed in the task. They don't find flow. It's like there's a shadow over them. or they're focused on the outcome. And they're less likely to get absorbed in the task, they don't find flow. It's like there's a shadow over them, of constantly feeling like,
因为他们只是在走过场，机械地完成音乐创作。是的，或者他们专注于结果。而且他们不太可能全身心投入到任务中。他们找不到心流。就像他们身上笼罩着一层阴影。或者他们专注于结果。而且他们不太可能全身心投入到任务中，他们找不到心流。就像他们身上笼罩着一层阴影，总是觉得，
well, I should be practicing more. I should be studying, as opposed to, I wanna study, I feel like practicing. This is exciting. One of the insights you talk about is that we're all looking for road maps to success, but you say the right tool might not actually be a map, but a compass. What do you mean by this item? I think that so many people, when they look to an expert guide or a mentor, they think they're going to get a set of directions. But you can't follow somebody else's map
嗯，我应该多练习。我应该学习，而不是“我想学习，我觉得很想练习。这太令人兴奋了。”你谈到的一个见解是，我们都在寻找通往成功的路线图，但你说正确的工具可能不是地图，而是指南针。你这个说法是什么意思？我认为很多人在寻找专家向导或导师时，以为自己会得到一套详细的路线。但你无法遵循别人的地图，
because no one is starting from the same place that you are. None of the experts or mentors that you look to for guidance began their journey on the exact same starting point that you did. They just have different skills, different strengths, different challenges, and that means their map is not going to be tailored for you. There's also the issue that they may not have all the directions, they may not remember them, they may not know them. So I think what we're looking for is a compass. Not to give you directions, but to give you direction.
因为没有人跟你的起点完全相同。你向其寻求指导的专家或导师中，没有一个人是在跟你完全相同的起点上开始他们的旅程的。他们只是拥有不同的技能、不同的优势、不同的挑战，这意味着他们的地图并不是为你量身定制的。还有一个问题是，他们可能并没有所有的路线指引，他们可能记不清了，或者他们可能根本不知道。所以我想我们寻找的是一个指南针。不是为了给你指路，而是为了给你方向。
A good compass tells you whether you're on the right heading. And that's what I think you want from a mentor to guide you. We talked earlier about the story of Arya Dickey, the rising baseball star who had not just one fall from grace but three falls from grace. So it looked like his career was over. You know, after the third time he got relegated to the minor leagues, but then he got some advice from pitching coaches that acted as a sort of compass. What did they tell him at him? Well, they basically set him down and said, this career is not going to work for you. You don't have the physical ability that you need to succeed. And if they had stopped there, he might have just retired.
一个好的指南针能告诉你，你现在的航向是否正确。这正是你希望从导师那里获得的指导。我们刚才谈到了阿亚·迪基（R.A. Dickey）的故事，这位冉冉升起的棒球明星不仅遭遇了一次挫折，而是遭遇了三次挫折。所以看起来他的职业生涯好像已经结束了。你知道的，在第三次被下放到小联盟之后，他从投手教练那里得到了一些建议，这些建议就像是一个指南针。他们当时对他说什么了？嗯，他们基本上让他坐下来，对他说，这条职业生涯对你不适用。你没有取得成功所需要的身体能力。如果他们当时就此打住，他可能就直接退役了。
But he was lucky to have some pitching coaches who gave him a compass. They said, look, you're going in the wrong direction. You're not going to make it back to the major leagues on the course that you're taking right now. But there might be another path for you. They said, you know, we've seen you throw this pitch. It was a strange looking pitch, but the pitching coaches recognized
但他很幸运，遇到了一些给他指明方向的投手教练。他们说，听着，你走错方向了。按照你现在选择的路线，你是不可能重返大联盟的。但你可能还有另一条路可走。他们说，你知道的，我们看过你投这种球。这是一个看起来很奇怪的球，但投手教练们认出
that he was holding the ball very similar to the way that you would grip if you were going to throw a knuckleball. And for a non baseball fans, what is a knuckleball at him? So a knuckleball is where instead of holding the ball in the palm of your hand with all your fingers wrapped around it, you take your index in your middle finger and you actually dig your fingernails right into the ball. So it almost looks like your hand is a part claw and you're holding the ball with your two knuckles, your first and second finger knuckles
他握球的方式非常类似于你投蝴蝶球（knuckleball）时的握法。对于不看棒球的粉丝来说，什么是蝴蝶球呢？蝴蝶球就是，你不是用手掌托着球、用所有手指包住它，而是用食指和中指将指甲直接抠进球里。所以看起来你的手有点像爪子，你用第一和第二指关节
sticking up in the air. And the knuckleball is a rare pitch. There are not a lot of pitchers who have used it successfully, but it can be pretty deadly because the way that you grip it stops it from spinning. It actually flies pretty flat. And that means it's gonna go slower, but it can also zigzag and just confuse the heck out of batters. And they said to RA, because the knuckleball is a slower pitch, it's pretty well aligned with your arm strength.
翘在空中的两个指节来握球。蝴蝶球是一种罕见的球路。没有多少投手能成功运用它，但它可能极具杀伤力，因为你握球的方式阻止了球的旋转。它飞行时几乎不旋转。这意味着它的速度会变慢，但它也会呈之字形飞行，把击球手搞得晕头转向。他们对R.A.说，因为蝴蝶球是一种速度较慢的球，它和你的手臂力量相当契合。
And because you've thrown this thing, you have a little bit of a feel for the way that you would release a knuckleball. And maybe you've thrown this thing, you have a little bit of a feel for the way that you would release a knuckleball. And maybe you can master this pitch and maybe it can salvage your career. So did he decide to take that advice? He decided to give it a shot, but he did not know where to start.
而且因为你以前投过这种球，你对释放蝴蝶球的手感有一点了解。也许你可以掌握这种球路，也许这能挽救你的职业生涯。那么他决定接受这个建议吗？他决定尝试一下，但他不知道从哪里开始。
None of his pitching coaches had any experience working with a knuckleballer. All they could do was give him a compass and say, general direction, if you want to make it back to the majors, learn how to throw this pitch that does not spin. And he decides to go for it. So at one point, he pictures himself standing in a doorway and executing the entire throw without letting his body touch the doorframe. So what I find interesting here is he's not just learning to throw this knuckleball, he's
他的投手教练都没有与蝴蝶球投手共事的经验。他们能做的就是给他一个指南针，告诉他大致方向：如果你想重返大联盟，就去学会投这种不旋转的球。于是他决定放手一搏。所以有一次，他想象自己站在一个门框里，完成整个投球动作，同时不让身体碰到门框。我觉得有意思的地方在于，他不仅在学习投蝴蝶球，他还在
actually developing a system that can teach him to throw the knuckleball. That's right, and it feels completely wrong to him. You know, it reminds me of something that my diving coach Eric Best always said to me. He would say, Adam, make it feel wrong. I don't want to make it feel wrong. I'm trying to do it right. He's like, yeah, but if you always do it in a way that feels right, then you're going to under-correct.
实际上开发一套能够教他投蝴蝶球的系统。没错，这让他感觉极其别扭。你知道的，这让我想起我的跳水教练埃里克·贝斯特（Eric Best）经常对我说的话。他会说：“亚当，要让它感觉别扭。”我可不想让它感觉别扭。我正努力做得对呢。他说：“对，但如果你总是用那种感觉对的方式去做，那你就会矫枉过正不足。”
You're not going to make a big enough change. Make it feel wrong, over correct, and that's how you get it right. And that's what Ra had to do. So he's picturing himself standing in a doorway. And basically, that means he's almost pinning his elbow to his body when he throws. So he kinda looks like a T-rex.
你做出的改变不够大。让它感觉别扭，矫枉过正，这才是你做对的方法。这也是R.A.必须做到的。所以他想象自己站在门框里。基本上，这意味着他在投球时几乎把手肘夹在身体两侧。所以他看起来有点像霸王龙。
By making those radical adjustments, he's able to unlearn the way he's always pitched, which is to try to maximize spin and learn to take the spin off the ball, but it's a long road. So you interviewed R.A. for your book. Tell me what, how his story turned out, what happened after he learned to throw this knuckleball? Well, he went in circles for years, basically three years. You know, he's backtracking, he's undoing all of the things that have made him good enough to be a minor league pitcher. And he feels like he's getting worse and worse at many steps along the way. But after all this effort, all this going backward and having to learn a new method and kind of
通过做出这些激进的调整，他能够忘掉自己一直以来的投球方式——那种试图最大化旋转的方式，并学会让球不再旋转，但这漫长的一路并不好走。所以你在书中采访了R.A.。告诉我，他的故事结局如何？在他学会投蝴蝶球之后发生了什么？嗯，他在原地打转了好几年，基本上是三年。你知道的，他在倒退，他在推翻所有让他足以成为一名小联盟优秀投手的东西。而且他在这一路的许多步骤中都觉得自己变得越来越糟。但在付出所有这些努力、所有这些倒退并不得不学习新方法以及某种程度上
reinvent his entire technique to pick up a different skill, he ends up moving forward. He spent the vast majority of 14 years toiling away in the minor leagues and he gets called back to the majors again. And that year, his earn run average makes him one of the 10 best pictures and all of baseball. And he signs a multi million dollar multi year contract with the meds. And what's crazy about this, Shankar is that in the year he was drafted, there were nine pictures picked ahead of him. Eight of them have already retired, and the ninth is never coming back to the majors, but RA is kind of just scratching the surface of his prospects. And at 35, he's
重塑他的整个技巧以掌握一门不同的技能之后，他最终向前迈进了。他把14年绝大部分时间都在小联盟里辛苦打拼，然后他再次被召回大联盟。那一年，他的防御率（ERA）使他成为整个棒球界最好的10名投手之一。他和大都会队（Mets）签了一份数百万美元的多年合同。而疯狂的是，尚卡尔，在他被选中的那一年，在他前面有9名投手被选中。其中8人已经退役，第9人再也没有回到大联盟，但R.A.才刚刚开始触及他潜力的表面。在35岁时，他
beginning to unlock his hidden potential. You know, he he ends up with a very, very triumphant finish. 2012, he's 37 years old, he makes his first all-star game, he sets a Metz franchise record for pitching 32 scoreless innings in a row, he leads the whole league in strikeouts, and he becomes the first knuckleballer in Major League Baseball history to win the Saiyung award for being the best pitcher in the whole league. One of the things that he did that's very striking is that he didn't go to one expert, one guru and basically say, teach me how to do this magical thing, which is I think what many of us do. He went to many people and tried to learn many things from many people.
开始释放他隐藏的潜能。你知道，他最终取得了非常非常辉煌的结局。2012年，他37岁，首次入选全明星赛，他创造了大都会队史连续32局无失分的纪录，他领跑全联盟的 strikeouts（三振数），并成为美国职业棒球大联盟历史上第一位赢得赛扬奖（Cy Young Award）的蝴蝶球投手，该奖项授予全联盟最好的投手。他做的一件非常引人注目事情是，他没有去找某个专家或大师然后说，教我怎么做这个神奇的事情——我想这是我们许多人会做的。他去了很多人那里，并试图从许多人身上学到很多东西。
Some years ago, there was a study by Monica Higgins at Harvard who looked at the career paths of lawyers who were navigating the path to partner. That study found something very similar to the path that Ari Dickey took. Tell me about that study. Yeah, it turned out that if you wanted to predict which lawyers would get promoted to partner, getting guidance from a single mentor didn't predict. So in other words, if you had one mentor in your court, that was not enough to increase your odds of getting promoted to partner. If you wanted to get promoted to partner,
几年前，哈佛大学的莫妮卡·希金斯（Monica Higgins）做过一项研究，她研究了律师们争取成为合伙人的职业道路。那项研究发现了一些与阿亚·迪基所走道路非常相似的东西。跟我讲讲那项研究吧。是的，结果表明，如果你想预测哪些律师能晋升为合伙人，从单一导师那里获得指导并不能预测成功。换句话说，如果你的阵营里只有一个导师，这不足以增加你晋升为合伙人的几率。如果你想晋升为合伙人，
you actually wanted to have multiple mentors guiding you. Different mentors are going to give you different directions. They all have different maps and if you even had two or three mentors you were more likely to make the climb to partner instead of seeing your career stall and that that seems to be because in part, multiple mentors are able to, you know, to point out different landmarks, different turns along the path, and then you can cobble their suggestions together into your own map that works for you. I want to talk about how having a sense of purpose can also inspire us to accomplish great things. You tell the story of Alison Levine who grew up in Phoenix, Arizona.
你其实需要有多位导师来指导你。不同的导师会给你不同的方向。他们都有各自的地图，如果你甚至有两三个导师，你更有可能成功攀登到合伙人的位置，而不是看到你的职业生涯停滞不前。这似乎在部分上是因为，多位导师能够指出不同的地标、路径上的不同转折，然后你可以把他们的建议拼凑成一张适合你自己的地图。我想谈谈使命感如何也能激励我们成就伟大的事情。你讲述了艾莉森·莱文（Alison Levine）的故事，她在亚利桑那州菲尼克斯长大。
At an early age, she got interested in climbing mountains, very cold mountains, but it didn't really look like a mountain climbing career was really on the cards for her. Tell me her story, Adam. Well, Alison was born with a hole in her heart. And she would, as a teenager, just pass out and have to go to the emergency room. And after a series of surgeries, the hole was closed and she got the thumbs up that she could climb,
很小的时候，她就对爬山产生了兴趣，非常寒冷的山，但看起来登山职业生涯并不在她的计划之中。亚当，讲讲她的故事吧。嗯，艾莉森出生时心脏有个洞。在青少年时期，她会经常昏厥并不得不去急诊室。经过一系列手术后，心脏的洞被补上了，她得到了可以登山的绿灯，
but she also had a circulatory disorder where in freezing weather, basically her arteries would stop sending blood to her toes and fingers. She would go numb and her risk of frostbite was heightened. So in 2002, Adam Allison's dream comes true. She overcomes many of the physical hurdles that she was born with. She's named Captain of the First Expedition by a group of American women to climb Mount Everest.
但她同时也患有一种循环系统疾病，在严寒天气下，她的动脉基本上会停止向脚趾和手指输送血液。她会失去知觉，冻伤的风险大大增加。所以在2002年，亚当，艾莉森的梦想成真了。她克服了许多生来就有的身体障碍。她被任命为美国女子登山队攀登珠穆朗玛峰的第一支探险队队长。
Tell me what happens during the climb. It's a very treacherous climb. There's one part where there's stuck at the Kumbu ice fall. So you have, she has 2,000 vertical feet of ice above her. And they've got to go really fast because as the sun comes out and it starts to melt, there's a possible ice crack. There might be an avalanche. They've got to move quickly. And Allison is not able to go fast because of her physical disabilities. And there's
告诉我攀登过程中发生了什么。这是一次非常险恶的攀登。其中有一段他们被困在了昆布冰瀑（Khumbu Icefall）。所以，在她上方有2000垂直英尺的冰。他们必须走得非常快，因为随着太阳出来冰开始融化，可能会有冰裂。可能会有雪崩。他们必须迅速行动。而由于身体残疾，艾莉森无法走得很快。而且
actually a guy behind her, as she's putting her foot on the ladder who says, you're never going to make it at this pace. If you can't go faster, you shouldn't be here. Like, maybe you should quit and go home. She keeps going slowly. Eventually, they get past the ice fall. And not long after that, a section ends up actually collapsing in an avalanche and another climber almost dies. But after almost two months, they get to the final stretch. They're in the death zone. That's the altitude where most people can actually
实际上她身后有一个家伙，当她把脚踩在梯子上时说，以这种速度你永远也登顶不了。如果你走不快，你就不应该来这里。就像，也许你应该放弃回家。她继续缓慢前行。最终，他们穿过了冰瀑。不久之后，其中一段在雪崩中实际坍塌了，另一位登山者差点丧命。但在将近两个月后，他们到达了最后的路段。他们身处死亡区。那是大多数人实际上能够
absorb enough oxygen to live. So they have supplemental oxygen, but Allison, because of her condition, has to take five or maybe ten breaths just to take one step. And so they're still moving slowly, they can see the peak, and then they run into another problem. Stormblowsen.
吸收足够氧气以生存的高海拔区域。所以他们有辅助氧气，但艾莉森由于她的病情，必须深呼吸五次甚至十次才能迈出一步。所以他们依然移动缓慢，他们能看到山峰，然后他们遇到了另一个问题：暴风雪袭来。
So they've spent two months getting to this point. I understand at this point they're less than 300 feet from the summit, and that's when the storm blows in. Yeah, and they've got to white out, the winds are extremely heavy. It's so dangerous that not only can they not go forward, they can't even wait it out, they have to turn around and go back down the mountain. So they end up climbing nearly 29,000 feet, looking at the summit and having to quit less than 300 feet from the top. Alison Swore, she was done with Everest, but a close friend urged her not to give up.
所以他们花了两个月才到达这一点。据我所知，此时他们距离峰顶不到300英尺，正是在那时暴风雪刮了起来。是的，他们遇到了白化天气，风非常大。太危险了，以至于他们不仅无法前进，甚至无法原地等待，他们必须转身下山。所以他们最终爬了近29,000英尺，看着峰顶，却不得不在距离山顶不到300英尺的地方放弃。艾莉森发誓她再也不登珠峰了，但一位密友敦促她不要放弃。
Her friend Meg kept telling her to try again and Alison said to her, I'll only do it if you go with me, but knew that Meg couldn't do it because she'd had lymphoma and her lungs were damaged. And then, sadly, in 2009, Meg had a lung infection and died. And Allison wanted to try to honor her memory and extend her legacy. And she said, all right, I'm going back to Everest. I'm going to climb it in Meg's memory. She carved Meg's name on her ice axe. She flew to Nepal and picked up as part of an expedition with a bunch of mountaineers who
她的朋友梅格（Meg）一直劝她再试一次，艾莉森对她说：“只有你跟我一起去，我才去。”但她知道梅格去不了，因为梅格得过淋巴瘤，肺部受损了。然后，不幸的是，在2009年，梅格感染了肺部并去世了。艾莉森想要缅怀她的记忆并延续她的遗志。她说：“好吧，我要回珠穆朗玛峰。我要为了梅格的记忆去攀登它。”她在冰镐上刻下了梅格的名字。她飞往尼泊尔，加入了一支由
were complete strangers. She ended up getting to the point where she had had to turn around before and she was starting to doubt herself. And she heard a voice behind her. It was a guide from another expedition, his name is Mike Horst, and he'd actually stayed behind to give her some encouragement.
完全是陌生人的登山者组成的探险队。她最终到达了她以前不得不转身返回的地方，她开始对自己产生怀疑。她听到身后有一个声音。那是另一支探险队的向导，名叫迈克·霍斯特（Mike Horst），他实际上留下来给她一些鼓励。
And he said, promised me you're gonna go farther than this. And she felt like, all right, Mike summited Everest a bunch of times. If he thinks I can do it, I can do it. And she keeps going and she reaches the top. But that's actually not all she accomplishes there. So she's summited the tallest mountain on Earth.
他说：“答应我，你要比这走得更远。”她觉得，好吧，迈克登顶过珠峰很多次。如果他认为我能做到，那我一定能做到。于是她继续前进并登上了顶峰。但事实上，这并不是她在那里取得的全部成就。所以她登上了地球上最高的山峰。
But this is also the last step for Allison in completing what's called the Adventurer's Grand Slam, where she's one of a few dozen people on Earth who's not only climbed the tallest peak on all seven continents, but she's also skewed to both the North Pole and the South Pole. Wow. So she's made it to the top of Mount Everest. I mean, seemingly an impossible goal given that she had
但这也是艾莉森完成所谓“探险家大满贯”（Adventurer's Grand Slam）的最后一步，在这个大满贯中，她是地球上仅有的几十人之一，不仅登上了所有七大洲的最高峰，还滑雪到达了北极和南极。哇。所以她登上了珠穆朗玛峰之巅。我的意思是，考虑到她
many health conditions as a child. She faced down obstacles in reaching this goal. She doubted herself. Other people doubted her. The odds were stacked against her. At one point, she quite literally got stuck. Looking back, she says that her proudest moment was not reaching the summit. It was the distance she traveled from Everest before she got back to the spot
小时候有多种健康状况，这似乎是一个不可能完成的目标。她在实现这一目标的道路上面临重重阻碍。她怀疑自己。其他人也怀疑她。形势对她极为不利。有一段时间，她字面意义上被困住了。回首过去，她说她最自豪的时刻不是登顶。而是她从珠峰出发，直到返回
where she had to turn around. What does she mean by this atom? Well, I think it's so easy to think that climbing a mountain, and this is true for any goal, is about reaching the destination. So she had a target of getting to the peak and she thinks the most meaningful thing that she could do is get there as a climber. But she realizes after going back to Everest the second time that this challenge is not about performance, it's about progress.
她不得不转身返回的那个地点所走过的距离。亚当，她这话是什么意思？嗯，我认为人们很容易认为爬山——对于任何目标来说都是如此——是为了到达终点。所以她有一个到达顶峰的目标，她认为她能做的最有意义的事情就是作为一个登山者到达那里。但她在第二次重返珠穆朗玛峰后意识到，这个挑战无关乎表现，而是关乎进步。
And I think we misunderstand progress. Most people think about progress is moving forward. I think sometimes it's about bouncing back. So it's not just the peaks you reach, it's also the valleys you cross. And Chunker I've come to believe that resilience is actually a kind of growth. That when you run into an obstacle like Allison did, and you have to turn around, that progress is actually reflected in the fact that she was able to get back on the mountain and get right back to the place where she had to turn around.
我认为我们误解了进步。大多数人认为进步就是向前迈进。我认为有时进步是关于绝处逢生。所以，这不仅关乎你到达的山峰，也关乎你穿过的山谷。尚卡尔，我开始相信，韧性实际上是一种成长。当你遇到像艾莉森那样遭遇的障碍，不得不转身返回时，这种进步其实体现在她能够重新回到山上，并径直回到那个她不得不转身返回的地方。
Psychologist Adam Grant works at the University of Pennsylvania. His book is called Hidden Potential, the Science of Achieving Greater Things. Adam, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Honored to be here, I think Hidden Potential clearly needed to be on Hidden Brain. Do you have follow-up questions for Adam Grant about achieving your goals? If you'd be willing to share those questions with a hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideasathydnbrain.org. Use the subject line, potential.
心理学家亚当·格兰特（Adam Grant）在宾夕法尼亚大学工作。他的书名叫《隐藏的潜能：成就伟大事业的科学》（Hidden Potential: The Science of Achieving Greater Things）。亚当，非常感谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。我很荣幸能来到这里，“隐藏的潜能”显然应该登上“隐藏的大脑”。你对亚当·格兰特关于实现目标有什么后续问题吗？如果你愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题词：potential。
That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. As we approach the final days of the year,
再次重复该邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。“隐藏的大脑”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Ani Murphy Paul）、克里斯蒂安·王（Christian Wong）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、瑞恩·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐藏的大脑”执行主编。随着一年中最后几天的临近，
we wanted to say thank you for making Hidden Brain part of your life in 2023. We know your time is a valuable asset and we really appreciate that you chose to spend it with us. We're looking forward to bringing you many more interesting ideas and conversations in 2024. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
我们想对大家说声谢谢，感谢你们让“隐藏的大脑”成为你们2023年生活的一部分。我们知道你们的时间是非常宝贵的资产，我们非常感激你们选择和我们度过这段时间。我们期待在2024年为大家带来更多有趣的想法和对话。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。
See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。